Про нього зняли документальний фільм, створили комікс, а президент України
особисто вручив йому нагороду за мужність.
Хлопцю нині 16. Це Андрій Покраса - юний аеророзвідник.
Допоміг ЗСУ вистежувати ворожі колони.
Допоміг знищити біля 100-150 одиниць техніки.
З перших днів вторгнення російської армії на Київщину село Колонщина
було буквально оточене ворожими військами. На цій вулиці Андрій вперше у житті
почув не галас однолітків, з якими грав у футбол, а вибухи снарядів.
Я знав, що вже все тепер буде інакше. Перші два дні ми готували нашу хату:
набирали воду, поки вона була. Танки були в стороні головної дороги в селі.
Ця дорога, до речі, зіграла немаленьку роль взагалі в нашій ситуації.
Вулиця, вона закрита садом яблуневим, і перегороджена блоками,
тому не видно будинків. Під час окупації цю вулицю знайшли в останню чергу
і встигли пограбувати лише будинок чи два, доки не прийшли ЗСУ.
Андрій добре знає рідні місця не лише тому, що живе тут змалку,
а через те, що роками дивився на всі ці краєвиди з висоти пташиного польоту.
А точніше - польоту його квадрокоптерів.
Це як вертоліт дитячий, але професійніше і більш стабільно.
І можна навіть політати нормально. І це якось так зацікавило,
що я потім пішов на курс авіамоделювання у нас в Києві.
З шести років, відколи хлопцю батьки подарували перший дрон,
він уміє керувати такими "пташками" і згори знімає відео про природу
та міста України. Втім до 27 лютого 2022-го року, яке змінило його життя
- він ніколи б не подумав, що у цій місцевості буде фільмувати російську техніку
та колони окупантів. На третій день війни тероборона почала шукати спеціаліста
з управління дронами. Сусіди підказали Андрія.
З нами зв’язався наш місцевий активіст, який запитав, чи є пілот.
А вони тоді не знали, що мені 15 років. Нас зв’язали з місцевим військовим.
Він сюди під’їхав. Він думав спочатку, що мій тато пілот, але потім виявилося,
що я пілот. Він сказав: "Він дитина. І це небезпечно".
Але крім Андрія ніхто з місцевих не міг управляти дронами.
Тож школяр таки став місцевим аеророзвідником для тероборони.
Запускали снарядів на 20 відсотків менше, ніж було техніки, тобто дуже економно було
і дуже треба була точна інформація, де вони знаходяться.
Тероборона та ЗСУ повідомляли йому завдання, він вистежував ворожі переміщення,
фіксував та передавав координати у штаб українських військових.
І все це - на відстані кількох кілометрів від позицій загарбників - в умовах окупації.
Тоді була стратегія - максимально безпечно. І навприсідки ходив.
Я із татом був, він мене координував, де мені стояти, куди мені йти.
Вони були там - невелика колона десь до 100 одиниць, там колона - 70.
Ця колона ще тільки їхала до Березівки. Знайшов ще там угруповання невелике
на недобудованому складі з артилерією.
Десь на день третій в мене було завдання знайти "С-300".
Півтора тижня щоденно з шостої ранку до десятої вечора Андрій вистежував
російські колони. Страху в хлопця не було. Батьки лише постійно пильнували,
аби Андрій був на зв’язку і далеко сам не заходив. Про знищену завдяки
своїй розвідці ворожу техніку Андрій говорить із гордістю.
Ми вдома сидимо і так: бах-бах-бах. І ми з татом сидимо: "Наші! Спрацювало!"
Вибухи, там починало диміти, "бавовна". Бігають, метушаться.
Через адреналін така крутість. Розуміння, що реально чимось зміг допомогти.
Та ворожі солдати теж часу не гаяли. 7 березня танки окупантів стояли
за 500 метрів від дому Андрія, росіяни перевіряли особи усіх місцевих жителів
і вбивали цивільних-патріотів. Українські захисники порадили батькам хлопця
вивезти його - адже про його співпрацю із ЗСУ могли дізнатися.
У мене був дрон, я не думаю, що нас би залишили живими.
Андрій з рідними вирішили евакуюватися з села.
Втім на шляху з Колонщини була одна зупинка - штаб ЗСУ в сусідньому районі.
Там на Андрія чекало ще одне відповідальне завдання, яке доручили наші військові
- допомогти ліквідувати окупантів з технікою, аби відбити один зі шляхів до Макарова.
Те, що школяр зробив далі, дозволило нашим бійцям просунутися,
а цивільним вирватися з окупації звільненою дорогою.
Від’їхали десь там на півтора кілометра, сфотографували, буквально пройшло хвилин п’ять.
Ми поїхали назад в штаб. Головний - я йому показую фото, координати,
які я зафіксував, він знаходить ці координати на карті. Два рази диктує
в таку велику рацію інформацію і буквально за дві хвилини таке прилітає: "Вжух!"
Після цього родина хлопця в ту ж мить вирушила з ним на захід країни.
Через кілька тижнів - у Польщу. Там юний герой закінчив 9 клас школи.
Втім вже влітку повернувся, аби знову бути корисним - уже як благодійник.
Разом із фондом Сергія Притули Андрій запустив грошовий збір на дрони для фронту.
Було класно зустрітись з людиною, яка увійде в історію України. Люди вдячні, що я допоміг.
На цьому популяризація добрих справ Андрія не припиналася.
Про історію хлопця створили комікс "Дроновод", зняли документальний фільм,
а влітку нагородою за мужність відзначив президент України.
Втім геть не популярності прагне нині 16-річний Андрій.
Каже, що хоче навчати інших керувати дронами та надалі збирати
благодійні кошти для ЗСУ. Крім цього, зізнається: не проти знову взяти до рук
свою "пташку" і вистежити окупантів для українських захисників.
Звичайно, якщо від мене буде потрібна допомога, я завжди допоможу -
можу навчити літати, можу далі літати. Рівень любові до своєї країни
настільки зашкалює. Я далі продовжую жити звичайним життям,
з тими самими друзями продовжую спілкуватися, жаль лише,
що багато друзів виїхали. Продовжую вчитись.
Мета Андрія на найближче майбутнє - закінчити школу і вступити до університету в Києві.
А мрія всього життя - проєктувати нові покоління дронів: не лише для військових,
а і для цивільних потреб - у мирній Україні після перемоги.